i remember hearing about these rumors
that people get motion sickness from
wearing headsets yeah i know
superstitions
superstitions and i'm just [ __ ]
you're not sick and i'm just like they
must just be weak-minded i ain't like
that i remember like the first time i
got like my uh valve index uh one of the
first games i bought was like uh pavlov
i think right oh it was like the it's
like the basically a virtual reality cs
go okay yeah and i remember
walking in that for like 10 seconds and
i just got immediate [ __ ] motion
sickness like like my brain
searched through like my the entire
history of humanity to like see if there
was any any kind of experience that
could like help regulate what i was
going through and it was just like yeah
nope i don't know what's going on right
now you're just gonna you're just gonna
feel sick right now
like the thing is i get motion sickness
even if it's like not a very like
movement intensive game like i get i get
sick after like 20 minutes of beat sable
yeah and like you you're not even
[ __ ] moving in that game yeah yeah
yeah i'm i'm totally fine on the motion
sickness part yeah i've only had one
one game that's given me motion sickness
yeah or like my vermont like make me
feel like oh
yeah it was like this ninja game santiro
or something yeah like you jump around
it's pretty sick but like you you jump
in the air yeah really [ __ ] high you
can change direction in the air again in
any direction oh so you can imagine it's
like jump up fly back and it's it's yeah
i'm getting sick just hearing it um but
it's good um but i the thing that i have
difficulty with is these headsets are
not light
yeah
they are uncomfortable to wear
yeah yeah yeah the index i love the
index amazing colors great piece of
hardware it is heavy and also the wires
can suck my dick i hate the wires yeah
um what i like about the oculus there's
no wires yeah like the thing the thing
is that i can't play a virtual or i
haven't been able to play a virtual
reality game more than a few hours
before either like my head gets tired or
i just want to chill out and i just want
to like because like i start sweating a
lot because you're wearing i swear yeah
yeah you you start like
i mean like you were basically wearing a
sink on your head
it's not comfortable at all and like i i
don't
i don't think i don't know if this is
just like boomer me talking but i i
can't see it being a real substitute for
just face-to-face interactions to me at
least
i mean like you know again like in order
for the metaverse thing to really pop
off it needs to be like vi headsets need
to be common enough in every household
as much as like say a computer is today
right and i just don't see it happening
for a while the oculus just isn't it
isn't quite there and it's also
expensive
i think the oculus is 300 bucks yeah
yeah and yeah that's that's uh that's
that's that's steep for a lot of people
yeah
um i think you know if you look at the
the
progress we've made in the past what
10 years when did the htc revive come
out that was the first big one wasn't
the first picture yeah what was that
when did the htc vive get released
nationally can you even look at what
vice versa i thought it was the oculus
rift was the first like real
big one that's the first one i heard it
was like the one that was with steam
yes that was the oculus rift that was
like the the og oculus rift that was
before facebook facebook with the mouse
yeah yeah htc vive was unveiled in march
2015. okay what about the oculus rift
the original the original august rift
was along
was the first time vr headsets became
like somewhat like a thing like to play
games like
okay
2016. oh okay
the five was the i i don't know i could
be totally wrong i i don't you could
google what the first vr headset is i
think it's fair to say at least to my
memory at least
that i think the htc vive was the first
headset that came out that like made
gaming seem like it
made sense yeah
on a it wasn't just a gimmick it was
like you could actually play games like
super hot was amazing
uh some of the demos are really good and
there were games coming out here and
there that were pretty good as well yeah
no i you know i think we thought there
was going to be a big boom but it there
really hasn't been it's just like many
games in the past seven years it's just
because the money isn't there right now
because it's so hard there's so many
barriers of entry um for buying like a
vr game so like the only big game i can
think of is half-life
um that's that's the only like game
where i look at this vr game and and
it's like it stands up as like a game
game you know it's like a lot of games
that i play on on vr it seems like a
tech demo with like it seems like a
glorified tech demo but like half-life
actually feels like a game and that's
because you know valve like invested in
it and i don't even like i can't believe
they made profit on it at all like
because i feel like that was more of
just them flexing to be like guys we
still make games remember remember
remember we made games we were a [ __ ]
real [ __ ] amazing uh game developer
back in the day we could still do it we
could still do it we still got a video i
played a lot of games on the vr and
super hot is still probably the best
yeah
that's the game that i get when people
come to my house and i'm like you want
to travel yeah super hot is the game
yeah try this yeah because it's so good
yeah it's so good it's super hot on beat
saber which is the best vr experience
i've probably had the same thing so far
it's
it's
i understand because like setting up the
valve index is like it's the best
headset right if you're on performance
yeah gaming
but my god but like i i think the k one
it
set that thing up and you need a space b
enough yeah which is another reason why
it like in japan is like not popular at
all no yeah i think my problem with vr
gaming that i've had so far is that it
turns gaming
uh for like for me gaming is like a
passive activity but vr gaming is
definitely an active activity for me
where i you know you feel physically
involved it doesn't feel like i like me
you know i i do like that as well but
like that you know
when you have like a [ __ ]
eight-hour 10-hour gaming session i
don't want to that that's like there's
only so long i can have yeah i can do
something active right for that period
of time like to me a lot of games are a
passive activity where you sit down on
the couch or sit at your pc you just
like chill there and i think it also
depends on like the the demographic as
well right like because i'm sure like
you know the average 10 year old has a
lot more [ __ ] energy to move around
for eight to 10 hours yeah yeah because
it's like you know someone who's in like
their 40s when i played a gorilla tag
yeah yeah it's just all like 10 year
olds yeah it's all 10 year olds well
like you know i think back to like when
i was well i think back to when i was 10
and the [ __ ] uh you remember the i
toy
the [ __ ] the camera on ps2
like when that [ __ ] came out and you had
to like physically move around and [ __ ]
like you know that like as a 10 year old
that's like [ __ ] yeah i could do this
for hours if you got me an eye toy now
i'd probably be like an hour and a half
and i'm done yeah but that to me that
was always like a gimmick you know like
that that one time you go to like your
cousin's house and they pull out the ddr
mat and you're like oh
okay we're we're having a ddr i'm not a
virtual boy yeah yeah yeah right right
matt that like barely registered yeah
yeah you got a [ __ ] stamp yeah
after like one like like one use or
something it's a shame because i think
that like vr gaming
is some of the most
fun and rewarding gaming
out
there done
problem is there's no incentive for
people to develop games for it like it's
hard and also it's like you know when
you're a kid and you i don't know if
you've ever had them uh i don't know
what they're called in australia but in
the uk the brand calls like uh scale
electrics it's like the you know those
cars you have to lay out that track yeah
and then you have the oh hot wheels all
right maybe kind of like hot wheels you
lay out the track and then you have
those things that like you turn the
buttons and they go
around the [ __ ] part what are they
called and what's the generic name for
them i think you're right
let me
it's like it's like that that's what vr
feels like right now
it needs to get to the point where
current gaming is where it feels like oh
you put on the headset you're good to go
yeah right now it's like i have to turn
on the two base stations i have to make
sure all the cables are plugged in oh i
gotta install this update oh the
tracking's off i gotta fix the tracking
it's like it's such a it's like going
back to that feeling as a kid where you
set up that that track and you set it
all up just for that like 30 minutes of
enjoyment yeah yeah and then you got to
put it all away again yeah yeah so like
until it gets to the point where it
doesn't feel like a slog to set up it's
not that it's active i think i think
it's it's it's like a pain in the ass to
set up and i know it is i've got mine
set up now to the point where it's as
painless as possible and it's still a
pain in the air yeah like
that five minutes of me turning
everything on and doing it all it's just
a little bit annoying for my my lazy
gamer brain to want to do well because
you're so used to just the the turn on
immediately start yeah right right yeah
that makes sense yeah uh it's called
skeleton uh that's the brand of yeah
yeah yeah is there a generic name for
that kind of product or i think there's
motorized cars yeah just like that yeah
you know how like because as a kid i
think we had a really dodgy one and it
was just a whole event setting it up
yeah yeah it took so long yeah but like
you as i remember as a kid you had way
more patience you know right
no not even as a kid but as a teenager
as well you know like you know i like
you know i tell people about the [ __ ]
uh the [ __ ] efforts i had to go
through to even just [ __ ] watch anime
or play some visual novels and you have
to you have to like download like seven
million zip files three tutorials about
how to like install this game
i think back to that now i'm just like
man imagine like imagine trying to do
that now we can just press one button on
steam to like play play a lot of these
like japanese underground games and all
that well even like console games right
like you had to like go into the bin to
look for the cartridge of the game and
then you had to [ __ ] put it in oh
it's not working pull it out blow on it
a little bit put it back in turn it on
wait for it to load now you just [ __ ]
turn on your switch and the download
game is right there yeah but like i i
mean i found my games cartridge yeah oh
really yeah i actually give them to my
like other people when i'm done with
them